it was another emotionally charged
episode of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians Sunday as kendall Jenner
sympathized with her alleged stalker
when I found out that Q had mental
health issues well I feel bad and the
rest of the family beefed up security
measures following Kim's Paris robbery
if it like weird of me though that I
feel bad for him I don't think he's
mentally there Kendall opened up about
experiencing anxiety after a stranger
was arrested for showing up at her home
in August the 21 year old model had to
testify in court something she felt
conflicted about having to see him in
court freaks me out can't we just send
him to a hospital where he can get the
help that he needs
meanwhile the rest of the family got
proactive about safety following Kim's
harrowing Paris robbery mom's saying I
should tint that window don't you think
I would worry about somebody walking
down the street looking in here it's a
security measure I'm not even joking you
guys you have to watch out yeah you
cannot post those pictures of all those
Rolex watch yeah like all the flashiness
on like the Instagram later in the show
an inconsolable Kim was so upset over
the incident Khloe told the Keeping Up
with the Kardashians producers to cut
the cameras we need to stop I just don't
want everything on camera right now and
Kim agreed to seek professional help
I've never bought therapy was the best
choice for me but I do want to be
responsible for my kids and my husband
and do whatever I have to do to get
through this but there was one happy
topic explored next week we'll see Kim
open up about the possibility of having
more kids
I'm gonna try to have one more baby I
want my kids to have siblings but the
doctors don't feel like it's safe for me